Location and
context are vitally important for
building the best possible mobile app.
The mobile nature of the platform is
that it is designed to be operated
anywhere, from sitting on a bus,
to sitting in your office, or beyond.
As such, the behavior of your app may
need to change based on your location.
For example, for a weather app such as
Sunshine, that you might have worked on
in the developing Android
app scores here at Udacity.
Should you really have to
type in your current zip code
in order to get a forecast?
Shouldn't the phone know where you are?
Indeed, if you take a look at
Android Fundamentals Part Two,
you'll learn how to do just that.
Or, for example, a music app.
It's usually great to have a detailed
UI that allows you to search for
your music, but
what happens when you're driving?
Shouldn't there be a less distracting
UI or perhaps voice operation?
In these scenarios, along with countless
others, how your device should behave
is determined by the location and
context of your phone.
You'll learn about the powerful APIs
that allow you to determine this
information for
your phone in a battery friendly way.